J'ai mémorisé 2000 caractères japonais et je vais vous expliquer comment j'ai fait.
Dans cette vidéo, je vais présenter des techniques de mémorisation
donc même si vous n'apprenez pas le japonais, cette vidéo peut être utile pour vous.
Pour tous les francophones qui regardent cette vidéo, ma chaîne est dédiée aux personnes
qui apprennent le français,
donc je parle volontairement lentement.
Si besoin, vous pouvez mettre en x1,5 ou même en x2.
Bref, en 2020, je suis allé pour la première fois au Japon et je suis tombé amoureux de la
langue japonaise.
Je ne sais pas vraiment pourquoi je suis tombé amoureux du japonais à ce moment-là,
puisque ça faisait déjà plusieurs années que je regardais des animés.
Mais c'est vraiment après ce voyage que je me suis dit qu'il fallait que j'apprenne le
japonais.
Et du coup, en rentrant en France, j'ai pris la décision de commencer l'apprentissage du
japonais
pour pouvoir un jour peut-être parler japonais.
C'est une langue difficile car c'est très différent du français.
Mais lorsque j'ai pris la décision d'apprendre cette langue, j'ai commencé un peu
naïvement,
c'est-à-dire que j'ai commencé sans trop me poser de questions.
C'est une langue difficile parce que quand on regarde du japonais, pour la première fois,
on ne comprend rien.
C'est une écriture très différente.
Et forcément, on apprend très rapidement qu'il existe trois alphabets.
Les hiragana, les katakana et les kanji.
Les hiragana et les katakana, c'est assez simple.
Ce sont deux alphabets de 46 caractères chacun.
Et donc, on peut rapidement arriver à lire et à écrire des mots en japonais.
Chaque caractère correspond à une syllabe, à un son.
Et donc, après, c'est juste un puzzle.
Mais ce n'est pas si simple parce que les japonais ont décidé d'emprunter et d'utiliser
des caractères chinois.
Ce sont les caractères qu'on appelle kanji.
Mais dans cette vidéo, pour simplifier, je dirai seulement caractère.
Et c'est là que le challenge commence.
Monsieur, il faut connaître combien de caractères pour pouvoir lire le japonais.
On considère qu'à la sortie de leurs études, les étudiants japonais doivent connaître 2000
caractères.
Pour, par exemple, pouvoir lire le journal.
Vous voulez dire 200, non ? Non, non. 2000.
Et pour chaque caractère, il existe des lectures différentes.
Par exemple, ce caractère qui veut dire "personne", on peut le lire "nin", "jin" ou bien
"hito".
Donc, il faut apprendre au moins 4000 pronunciations différentes.
"Omae wa mou shindeiru".
Bref, une grosse difficulté dans l'apprentissage du japonais, c'est d'apprendre ces 2000
caractères.
Si vous ne connaissez pas ces caractères, vous ne pouvez pas lire le japonais.
Et il se trouve que je les ai appris et je vais vous expliquer comment j'ai fait.
Un point important dans l'apprentissage des langues, c'est la mémorisation.
Et grâce au japonais, j'ai découvert des méthodologies pour mémoriser le plus efficacement
possible.
Alors, il n'y a pas de recette miracle.
Il faut travailler pour apprendre 2000 caractères.
Mais en utilisant les bonnes méthodes, on peut gagner beaucoup de temps.
Cette méthode s'organise autour de trois points.
Et on peut commencer tout de suite.
Le premier point, c'est utiliser un système SRS.
Je m'explique.
La mémoire, c'est un peu comme un mille-feuille.
Il y a plein de couches ou d'étages qui vont de la mémoire court terme à la mémoire long
terme.
Et du coup, quand on apprend quelque chose,
on essaye de pousser au maximum cette information dans la mémoire long terme.
La mémoire court terme, c'est par exemple quand vous allez prendre un train,
vous sortez votre billet pour regarder le numéro de votre place,
vous voyez voiture 14 siège 72,
vous remettez le billet dans votre poche
et vous avez déjà oublié le numéro de votre place.
Ah ! Attends, c'était voiture 16, place 98 ?
A l'inverse, la mémoire long terme, c'est par exemple se souvenir d'une publicité qu'on a
vu il y a plus de 20 ans.
Il y a donc plusieurs étages dans la mémoire
et il faut essayer de stocker les informations dans notre mémoire long terme pour être sûr
de ne pas tout oublier.
Et pour ça, on va utiliser un système SRS pour Spaced Repetition System.
Imaginez que je suis un Français qui essaye d'apprendre l'anglais.
Je dois mémoriser beaucoup de vocabulaire et pour ça je vais utiliser un système SRS.
Le fonctionnement est assez simple.
Je vais créer des cartes de mémoire avec par exemple un mot sur le recto "none"
et sa traduction en français sur le verso "aucun".
L'objectif, c'est donc de mémoriser que "none" ça veut dire "aucun".
Pour cela, le système SRS va organiser les révisions dans le temps.
Il va espacer les révisions dans le temps, d'où le nom de Spaced Repetition System.
Le premier jour, le logiciel montre la carte avec marqué "none"
et je dois me rappeler que ça veut dire "aucun".
Ici, deux options.
Soit je dis "oui, je me rappelle la signification de "none" ou "non, je ne me souviens
pas".
Si je réponds "non", le système SRS va me faire réviser la carte le jour suivant, le
lendemain.
Alors que si je réponds "oui", il va me faire réviser la carte dans trois jours.
Ça dépend des paramètres, mais plus on se souvient d'une carte, plus le système va espacer
les révisions.
Dès qu'on répond "non", il va nous faire réviser plus souvent.
Les révisions espacées, c'est pour être sûr que l'information est en train de descendre
dans les étages de notre mémoire.
Grâce à la répétition, on mémorise et plus on espace dans le temps les révisions,
plus on est sûr que l'information est bien en train de descendre dans notre mémoire long
terme.
Et du coup, pour apprendre 2000 caractères japonais,
la première chose que j'ai faite, c'est d'utiliser un système SRS.
Alors, j'ai utilisé un site payant dédié à l'apprentissage du japonais qui s'appelle
"Wanikani",
mais ce genre de système est utilisable pour tout ce qui concerne la mémorisation.
L'outil gratuit le plus populaire, c'est "Anki", qui veut littéralement dire
"mémorisation" en japonais.
Vous pouvez créer des cartes sur n'importe quel sujet.
Il y a par exemple des étudiants en droit ou en médecine qui utilisent ce logiciel.
Une fois que vous avez créé des cartes, Anki organise vos révisions
et chaque jour vous allez avoir un certain nombre de cartes à réviser.
Les informations que vous apprenez vont petit à petit descendre dans votre mémoire long
terme.
Anki, c'est un logiciel très populaire et il y a plein de tutoriels sur YouTube,
donc si ça vous intéresse, je vous laisse regarder.
Le deuxième point, c'est de construire une routine et utiliser des statistiques comme les
streaks et les heatmaps.
Pour le bien de tous, je vais le dire avec l'accent français.
Ce point est directement lié à l'utilisation d'un système SRS.
Et pour ma part, j'ai découvert ça avec le site Wanikani que j'ai utilisé pour apprendre
les 2000 caractères japonais.
En gros, quand j'ai commencé à utiliser cet outil, j'ai rapidement installé des extensions
qui affichaient des statistiques
et notamment un streak et une heatmap.
Le streak, ou plutôt en français, le nombre de jours consécutif.
C'est le nombre de jours à la suite où vous apprenez quelque chose ou vous utilisez
l'outil.
Par exemple, Duolingo est très populaire pour ça.
L'application nous pousse à réviser tous les jours et on a un compteur de jour qui affiche
le nombre de jours consécutif.
Cette statistique nous aide à rester motivé et plus on révise chaque jour, plus on a envie
de garder un streak élevé
et plus on va apprendre l'habitude de réviser un peu chaque jour.
Et c'est pareil avec la heatmap, c'est un outil qui nous donne un aperçu sur tous les jours
où on a révisé.
Chaque petit carré représente un jour et il va être plus ou moins coloré selon le nombre
de révisions qu'on a fait.
Malheureusement, je n'ai plus accès à ma heatmap Wanikani, mais ça ressemblait à quelque
chose comme ça.
Et d'ailleurs, je me souviens d'avoir eu un streak supérieur à 1000 jours, donc pendant
presque 3 ans, j'ai utilisé Wanikani tous les jours.
Ces statistiques, elles ont un objectif.
Construire une routine, construire une habitude.
Personnellement, j'ai construit cette habitude grâce à ces statistiques sur Wanikani.
Et d'ailleurs, vous avez exactement les mêmes disponibles sur Anki.
C'est quelque chose de très commun.
Mais à quoi ça sert ?
Et bien pour ça, je vais vous parler du livre Atomic Habits.
C'est un livre de développement personnel et c'est un best-seller qui parle justement des
effets positifs de la construction d'une habitude.
Quand on construit une habitude, l'action devient de plus en plus automatique et donc de
moins en moins difficile.
Une habitude, c'est quelque chose qu'on fait quasiment automatiquement.
Grâce à la répétition, quelque chose de difficile comme réviser pendant une heure des
caractères japonais devient de plus en plus facile.
Plus c'est facile, plus on est sûr de le faire.
Quand on construit une habitude, on a de meilleurs résultats sur le long terme.
Car les effets positifs se cumulent, il y a un effet boule de neige grâce à la répétition.
Si vous révisiez une fois par semaine, vous allez oublier plein de choses.
Si vous faites un peu tous les jours, ça reste toujours frais dans votre tête.
Quand on construit une habitude, c'est un gain de temps et d'énergie.
Dans tous les cas à prendre 2000 Kanjis, ça demande des heures et des heures de révision.
Il sera toujours plus efficace de passer 20 minutes par jour à réviser, plutôt que de
faire deux heures une fois par semaine.
Mentalement, c'est beaucoup plus simple de se dire, le matin, je fais 20 minutes et après,
c'est fini.
Que d'arriver le samedi matin et de se dire, oh putain, la flemme de passer deux heures à
réviser.
Et plus on va répéter l'habitude, plus la charge mentale de devoir réviser va diminuer,
parce qu'on va avoir de moins en moins l'impression de faire quelque chose de difficile.
Et enfin, quand on construit une habitude, on renforce notre identité.
Si vous commencez à faire du sport un peu chaque jour, vous devenez un sportif.
Si vous lisez des livres un peu chaque jour, vous devenez un lecteur.
Si j'apprends le japonais un peu chaque jour, je vais devenir japonais.
Je suis japonais, je suis né au Japon et je suis...
Non, on devient quelqu'un qui apprends sérieusement le japonais.
Et d'ailleurs, pendant toutes mes études, j'étais nul en langue étrangère.
J'ai étudié l'espagnol pendant 7 ans et je suis très mauvais.
J'ai toujours eu cette image de moi comme quelqu'un de mauvais pour apprendre les langues
étrangères.
Et depuis que j'étudie un peu chaque jour le japonais, ça a complètement changé.
Non seulement je me dis que je suis bon pour apprendre des langues étrangères,
mais aussi les personnes autour de moi me voient comme quelqu'un de doué et de déterminé.
Ça peut paraître bête dit comme ça, mais je pense que c'est quelque chose qui joue
un rôle important dans ce genre d'apprentissage.
Construire une habitude, c'est donc hyper important.
Et voici quelques conseils pour vous aider à la construire.
Mon conseil, c'est de la faire le matin au petit déjeuner,
comme ça après le reste de la journée, vous n'avez plus à y penser.
Plus c'est régulier, plus la charge mentale va diminuer.
J'ai appris le piano pendant trois ans et au début j'habitais dans un petit appartement
parisien.
Je devais ranger mon piano dans un placard et le sortir à chaque fois pour m'entraîner.
Et devinez quoi ? Je ne m'entraînais quasiment jamais.
J'ai déménagé dans un appartement plus grand.
Mon piano était toujours installé au même endroit et je n'avais qu'à appuyer sur "on" et
je pouvais m'entraîner.
Parce que c'était plus évident, je me suis plus entraîné.
C'est vrai pour n'importe quel type d'habitude, il faut que ce soit évident et facile.
Quand je lis le soir, je m'endors hyper rapidement, c'est vraiment très agréable.
Quand je fais un running, après j'aime bien boire un coca zéro.
C'est pas très bon pour la santé, mais c'est très agréable.
Le matin, je bois toujours un café, c'est un moment que j'aime bien.
Et maintenant, je bois un café en faisant mes cartes sur mon outil SRS.
C'est agréable.
Bref, il faut trouver des moyens, des façons de rendre votre habitude agréable.
Votre habitude doit aussi être satisfaisante.
Vous devez pouvoir voir qu'elle progresse.
Quand je cours, mes statistiques sont enregistrées sur Strava.
Et je vois le nombre de kilomètres que je fais chaque semaine.
Chaque jour où j'utilise mon outil de SRS, mon streak augmente et ma heatmap se remplit.
C'est satisfaisant.
Surtout n'oubliez pas, une habitude, ça ne se construit pas du jour au lendemain.
Au début, ça risque d'être difficile, alors gardez un œil sur votre streak et sur votre
heatmap
et un jour, vous allez réaliser que c'est devenu une habitude.
On a notre outil de SRS.
On construit une habitude.
Maintenant, il reste une dernière chose.
La mémoire, c'est un muscle.
Plus on l'entraîne, plus elle devient efficace.
Mais comme pour le sport, il y a des techniques plus ou moins efficaces.
Il y a d'ailleurs des championnats du monde de mémoire et les personnes qui participent
peuvent mémoriser des quantités d'informations énormes en très peu de temps.
Alors, il y a peut-être une histoire de talent, mais c'est surtout de l'entraînement.
Si vous pensez que vous êtes nul pour mémoriser, c'est une erreur.
C'est juste que vous ne vous êtes pas assez entraîné.
Je vais développer un exemple pour apprendre un caractère japonais,
mais à la fin, c'est pour vous expliquer les différentes techniques de mémorisation.
Donc, même si tout ce que j'explique sur les caractères japonais vous semble bizarre,
à la fin, ce sont des techniques que vous pouvez appliquer pour tout.
Pour apprendre des caractères japonais, il y a un fonctionnement assez simple.
On apprend en premier des radicaux, ce sont des petits morceaux de caractères,
pour ensuite pouvoir les associer pour apprendre plein de Kanjis différents.
Par exemple, on a le radical "lune", le radical "bouche" et le radical "fil".
Pour apprendre ce genre de radicaux, on utilise souvent des images, ça aide à mémoriser.
Par exemple, sur le site que j'utilise, Wanikani, on a ces images.
La lune, on voit une image de lune, la bouche, pareil et le fil.
Alors, ça n'est pas vraiment utilisable pour notre alphabet, pour le français par exemple,
mais gardez en tête qu'utiliser des images, c'est toujours utile pour mémoriser.
Et ensuite, on associe ces radicaux et ça donne ce caractère, la soie.
Quand on apprend le caractère pour la soie, on essaye d'identifier les radicaux,
donc il y a le fil, la bouche et la lune.
Ce caractère se lit qui nous.
Et donc maintenant, l'objectif c'est de mémoriser tout ça.
Et pour ça, on va créer une histoire débile, vraiment la plus débile possible.
Dans notre histoire, il faut qu'il y ait la lune, une bouche, un fil, de la soie
et quelque chose qui sonne comme Kinu.
Je vous donne mon exemple.
Imaginez, c'est un soir de pleine lune.
Il fait nuit, mais dehors, la lumière de la lune est très forte.
Vous sortez et vous voyez la lune, une grosse lune bien ronde.
Et là, d'un coup, vous commencez à avoir quelque chose qui sort de votre bouche.
C'est un fil, un fil de soie.
Et plus vous tirez dessus, plus le fil sort, il sort à l'infini.
C'est hyper désagréable, comme quand vous trouvez un cheveu dans votre nourriture.
Vous êtes dehors à la lumière de la lune et vous sortez ce fil de votre bouche.
Et d'un coup, vous remarquez que vous êtes tout nu.
Et vous commencez à entendre un voisin qui crie "Qui est nu ??".
Il le répète en boucle, et de plus en plus vite, qui est nu, qui est nu, qui est nu, qui
Kinu.
Donc pour résumer, vous êtes dehors, vous voyez une belle pleine lune,
et vous êtes en train de retirer un fil de votre bouche.
Et en même temps, vous entendez quelqu'un qui crie Kinu, Kinu, Kinu.
J'ai demandé à ChatGPT de me générer une image pour vous montrer,
mais l'important, c'est de l'imaginer.
Le but de cette histoire, c'est de mémoriser un ensemble d'informations.
Les radicaux, la lune, la bouche, le fil,
la signification du caractère, la soi, et sa prononciation, Kinu.
On crée une seule histoire avec toutes les informations, c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
mémoriser.
Pour ça, on utilise plusieurs choses.
La mémoire fonctionne par association.
Pour retenir une information, il faut la relier à quelque chose qu'on a déjà mémorisé.
C'est plus efficace.
Dans cet exemple, on apprend les radicaux en premier, parce qu'après,
tous les caractères qu'on va mémoriser vont être mémorisés par association.
On va juste assembler des radicaux pour former des caractères.
On mémorise mieux avec des images.
Quand on crée une histoire, on crée une image.
C'est le même principe que pour les radicaux.
On utilise des images pour mémoriser.
Plus notre histoire est vivante, mieux on va la mémoriser.
Quand vous pouvez ressentir votre histoire, vous allez la mémoriser plus facilement.
Si j'ai donné l'exemple du fil qui sort dans notre bouche,
comme quand on trouve un cheveu dans notre nourriture,
c'est justement pour associer cette histoire à une sensation qu'on connaît
et qui est particulièrement désagréable.
Au début, ça prend du temps à créer ce genre d'histoire,
mais après, ça devient une habitude.
A la fin, j'ai inventé des histoires bizarres comme ça dix fois par jour.
Alors, bien sûr, parfois on n'a pas besoin de faire tout ça.
Parfois, juste en connaissant les radicaux, on peut mémoriser rapidement.
Mais si vous avez une carte dans votre système SRS qui revient tous les jours
et que vous avez du mal à mémoriser,
prenez cinq, dix minutes et essayez de faire l'histoire la plus bizarre possible.
Et ça, c'est applicable à plein de choses, pas seulement pour les caractères japonais.
Il existe d'autres techniques de mémorisation,
mais elles ne sont pas forcément utiles dans l'apprentissage d'une langue.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur ces techniques,
le livre "Moonwalking with Einstein" est intéressant.
Et donc voilà comment j'ai appris 2000 caractères.
Pour résumer, j'ai travaillé chaque jour pendant 3 ans en construisant une routine, une
habitude.
J'ai utilisé un outil SRS et j'ai utilisé des techniques de mémorisation.
Pour finir, ce n'est pas une recette miracle.
Comme pour le sport, il faut s'entraîner.
Plus vous vous entraînez, plus vous allez progresser.
Également, ça ne sert à rien de se comparer.
Des personnes ont appris tous ces caractères en moins d'un an.
Donc il y aura toujours quelqu'un de meilleur que vous.
Alors prenez le temps.
Le pire pour une habitude, c'est d'arrêter.
Si vous allez trop vite, vous allez faire un burn out et abandonner.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout.
À la prochaine !